all right well cool we want we want to
first thank you for taking time out of
your schedule to join us here today is
to talk about the upcoming online
release of goodbye promise we're doing
it one week from today on August
thirteenth I'm looking forward to it you
guys had just sent me the link but I
haven't had a chance to see it yet
myself so I look forward to it like the
rest of everyone ya know no worries we
know that you're very busy coo and we we
just totally admire you there's few
people an independent film that we
respect more than you um you know we're
backwards of manchild and we can't wait
for you to go into production and before
we kind of totally dominate you know
your thoughts with our release and our
world is there anything that you would
like to share or say about manchild I've
just been revising for the last year so
you know I had done the Kickstarter
campaign when I did because I just got
it into a couple of screenplay things
and I thought that it was good timing
but then delving back in and going
through however many drafts I went
through it was just a process of you
know trying to take it from what I hoped
would be taking it from good to great
and I'm almost there with a script and
I'm going to be going out with it to
people who have been waiting for for you
know a year in some cases so hopefully
big news soon but no big news now so I'm
just looking forward to taking to the
next step yeah and thank you for saying
that about me I mean I'm a big fan of
your show and you know this is going to
be an interesting discussion about
distribution because I don't have a
whole lot of experience with
distribution the only thing I
distributed was a web series and we
didn't make any money off of that we
didn't try to make any money off of that
but I look forward to talking about it
yeah we're alright so yeah we're gonna
work over just about to get it to it you
know we just want to kind of light lay
down sort of like the rules that are the
the framework of the you know just to
hold the whole thing here so essentially
we haven't really shared this idea with
anybody yet returning to you first you
know we
you the fact that you do run no film
school the kind of content that you put
on there we know privately you've
expressed interest in sort of
distribution and this sort of thing so
we feel like you're someone that we can
turn to as sort of a mentor and we want
you to just be open be candid and we're
going to do our best we've kind of kind
of kept this under the wraps for a
little while now um you know we started
having these ideas a while back and so
we're going to kind of open up here and
we want you the sort of question us um
any questions that kind of mind and the
idea is any feedback we just want to be
totally candid we're going to do the
same you know where we're related all
out beginning now because we're getting
ready to do something that that's that's
ambitious that we're going to get into
just momentary great yeah and we just
have to throw the disclaimer out there
that we're not really pitched people i'm
a terrible pitch person and it's not
something that we've totally worked on
our full pitch and I'm sure there's ways
to kind of doctor it up and pretty it up
and we're hoping to find out what those
ways are no we just wanted to present
our plan to you and just okay here you
got me well if there's one thing I've
done over the over the last two years
its pitch that's like it's been my my
job it's like what am I actually going
to make a film you know but I've
certainly pinched a lot so uh oh I'll
sit on the other side of the table for
once here and there you go you know and
before we go right to sort of the idea
oh you know we want to further lay the
foundation let's start off with if
manchild was finished today um would
film festivals be your first path to
distribution it's big question um it's
interested me obviously the roll of film
festivals is is rapidly changing and I
think getting into the prestigious
festivals can probably do you a lot of
good especially if you're trying to sell
it for distribution or get it acquired
or something you're the role of the non
major film festivals is certainly
different in that light because people
aren't acquiring anything so I guess the
question is like
do you try to get into film festivals
for the prestige and the recognition and
the laurels or do you also try to get
into film festivals to tour and make
some money yourself and get exposure for
your screening fees and that kind of
thing I think the former yes I would but
I don't think they I mean obviously
they're changing in terms of like
festivals are becoming distributors with
Sundance and Tribeca and a lot of these
companies who are not just festivals
anymore but they also actually acquire
films and distribute them via VOD and
some theatrical release but that role is
definitely changing and I don't know
that like let's say that that if your
film gets into Sundance or con or
Tribeca Toronto or one of those do then
go on to tour for a year and then your
movie comes out a year later like that
is not something that I'd be interested
in doing but I think getting into one
for those first few festivals could be a
big launching point but there are plenty
of success stories of people who haven't
and who have just gone on and found an
audience online and you guys obviously
have an audience online so that may lead
you to your next question yeah you know
I think we sort of share like the same
thoughts there you know I you know I
want to be able to turn to film
festivals ideally like you want to be
able to turn to that that top-tier film
festival because like I said it could be
a great launching pad but yeah but you
know I guess I also kind of I look at it
is sort of like the studio independence
I've kind of taken over that world and
it becomes very difficult for smaller
films that don't have those recognizable
names to just to get into those
festivals that mean to be honest I mean
it does happen but it it's increasingly
difficult and so and it so it becomes a
big waiting game and I think you pointed
out there the fact that you know staying
on film festivals for a really long
period of time you know that what you're
getting out of them sort of declines as
you go along and so why keep the film
from your audience that
that's kind of rum yeah we share the
same thoughts there why so once man
child is totally finished have you given
any thought to how you will release it
ah so far away but have I given thought
yes do I have any idea and that's going
to be no Olivia you know and I think
that's why all of us keep tabs on all
the stories and and you know whether
that be louis ck and Aziz Ansari
releasing something drm-free for five
dollars to their audience and having
success with that or you know in these
startups like v HX or other companies
that are better you know dystrophy or
dynamo player and distribute these that
are sort of enabling a direct audience
distribution I don't think we've seen
that success story yet an independent
film I think all of us would want to be
that success story but you know it's one
thing for us to all to have a manifesto
and to say this is what I want to do
with my life with my movie but I think
there are probably different plans for
different movies in terms of knowing who
your audience is I think with goodbye
promise you guys have a definite target
audience and you know plenty of people
can identify with wanting to be an after
more than anything and not knowing how
to make that happen and that's where
your stories about and so there are you
know tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of actors out there who can
identify with that and so knowing the
audience and the size of the audience
that probably affects what's best for a
movie and I don't know those things yet
with my film being in the script stage
but I think for any of us to say oh
here's the approach that all movies
should be distributed in would be you
know selling yourself short in terms of
knowing what's best for each individual
work yeah yeah not totally agree with
that you know and you touched on sort of
the big names to know because you know
and that's not something we want to
touch on is we've seen ed burns we've
seen Morgan Spurlock and kevin smith
amanda palmer louis ck all these people
go direct to their audiences have
success but the prevailing opinion
always that like you said an unknown
artists or people may be in our room
like that's not for us you have to be an
established name what are your thoughts
on that because it's something that when
I hear over and over again it kind of
fires me up I don't adjust it just fires
me up because I believe that the
opportunity is there for us to try to at
least go for it what we see people may
be frozen in the tracks and not willing
to go after I just want to hear your
thoughts on that yeah I mean I think
what you guys have to do the film
courage obviously helps you a lot in
that respect because you know your names
are recognized and you do have a your
own platform similar to me with no film
school of setting hey you know where
people in the independent film industry
we're not just here for the week of the
month of the year like we're in it for
the long haul and here's our here's our
life's work you know come check it out
so I think that can help but obviously
none of us are you know Kevin Smith or
Morgan Spurlock I think in lieu it's
easy to say if you don't have a built-in
audience you can't find one you know but
I think that sort of on the internet
where it's not a matter of geography
it's more a matter of a niche it can be
possible to find people who are
interested in a topic and you've seen
that a lot on like documentaries have
been successful and Kickstarter because
they're about a topic that people care a
lot about and so for from my movie it's
basketball for yours it's acting I think
those can be really helpful hooks for
people to know that it you know it's not
just a drama about a relationship it's
like a drama about a particular
relationship and people who are been
through that themselves are going to be
interested in that so I you know
hopefully with social media and you know
for you guys it may be I think I think a
lot of it is about finding amplifiers so
it's not just but you know who can this
movie get in front of whose attention
can it get that and they can amplify it
to a larger audience and and so
for acting obviously there's millions of
actors out there but also groups like I
don't know what you guys have in LA but
here we have backstage or actors access
or those kinds of things like there are
you know groups that maybe would be
interested in the filming can help
amplify the audience beyond your own
personal following I think that can help
I mean it's not about you know tens of
millions of people seeing or a movie
necessarily but for all people at our
level to consider it a success it may
just be you know a few thousand and
that's what we're going for yeah
absolutely yeah if we sent to you that
we feel that one of the greatest
platforms in the world for us to launch
goodbye promise already exists what
would be your guests do you have a I
platform in terms of just like any a
website or write in terms of
distributing the film online for the
audience to see what would be your
guests what would you say I don't know I
mean I don't know your guys plan you
know we're leading to something but yeah
that we're kind of steering you a
certain way but yeah so you is there one
in particular that you think is the most
beneficial most favorite I mean you know
I think the thing that I've learned from
running no film school is that if you
start off and you put all your eggs in
one basket and you bet on one thing that
you're going to be surprised and so for
me it's always been well let's try all
of these platforms and see which ones
are working and then focus our attention
on those things so you know I've always
said I've always thought that like
something like distributor is really
interesting because they try to get your
movie on itunes and amazon VOD and hulu
and all these things at once and then
you sort of find out where your audience
is going to watch it and that's the one
that you promote the most I would be
hesitant to certainly you guys own your
movie you have control over it so
there's no reason to be exclusive 10
platform or service or anything I would
think that you know the multiple
approach might would be the one that I
would go with but if you guys think you
know exactly where you want to put it
then you know go for that absolutely
well you know we'll see you know I
because at the same time we agree with a
lot what you're saying there and and and
and I think we do want to open open the
film up to a lot to a lot of the
different platforms are mentioning we're
very much interested in distributors
part of what we'd like to do to give
ourselves a chance at itunes in in hulu
so here-here's we're coming from cool
let you know let's further kind of bring
us up to speed here so up to date we
started you know we started working on
goodbye promise as we started film Kurt
you know so this goes back to like 2009
is when we were actually shooting the
film we've done sort of pickups along
the way in 2010 and even this past year
still adding little things to the phone
um and so we've actually put a lot more
time into building film courage than we
have in working on this film that's part
of why it's taking so long is because
film courage is kind of grown into its
own things so but just talking I
understand completely yeah so you know
as we've talked to so many filmmakers
and now and as we've learned and gained
from so many filmmakers you know one
thing we've certainly seen is in the
distribution world with distributors you
know we've seen a lot a lot of
filmmakers sort of cheated you know in
the sense that you know deals that they
have signed like contract with
distributors to release their film where
we're payments weren't coming in you
have a case with Alex Holdridge with in
search of midnight kiss where his movie
made two million dollars globally and
then a couple years later at the time we
spoke to him he had received like
nineteen thousand dollars back you know
you hear a lot of stories like that you
hear stories of artists going to these
distributors and then having to take the
distributor to court you know as a way
to try to get their money
no se you know obviously stories like
that kind of scare the heck out of us
you know it makes us you know and and
even now like here we are we're on the
verge of releasing this we can't
necessarily reel off I handful of
distributors to say okay like these are
the reputable distributor's liked these
are the people you even target like why
is it so difficult so that that's that's
really frustrating and then you have it
where with film festivals you know we
think they serve a lot of good you know
we love film festivals but we don't
necessarily want to go the film festival
route because of the time invested you
know we we just spoke to some filmmakers
the other day who they waited five
months to get into their first film
festival um and then and then from there
they proceeded to be to go to the film
vessels for about a year so you know you
to me I feel like so much momentum as
lost along the way now we did that a
little bit with our previous film night
for the wedding um where we did we did
some film festivals and we did some of
our own screenings but then when it
finally gets around to to getting the
film online it's like the people that
were excited at the very beginning
you've sort of lost all that momentum
along the way so that that's the main
reason it's just the time that it takes
for all that to happen and we'd love to
say hey let's use a service like tug but
we're coming from with that is the
studio system they so dominate the
theatrical world and it is so hard
especially for like film like ours that
doesn't have like any name that jumps
out at you to really compete in that
space you know what we learned about the
studio world is they have several
hundred millions of dollars that they're
willing to spend you know like whether
it be like 30 40 50 60 100 million
dollars on advertising and then whatever
the film costs like they're willing
they're willing to take that loss
theatrically so that they can make it
back up and in the digital world in the
DVD world we obviously can't afford that
you know we can't we just can't compete
in that space yeah so for a long while
we've been thinking like okay we gotta
what we like to try to do is we like to
try to give it online we like to try to
are our people that watch the film and
react to it give them a chance to
immediately share the film so if they
like it they're in a position to
immediately share it and so since the
time that you were doing your manchild
campaign so now there's been an idea
that's been floating around in the back
of our head and terminal in terms of
home you know you see all the excitement
that happens with crowdfunding you know
and it's gotten to a point now where
there's more excitement that happens in
funding a film then there is when the
film is actually done in you're
releasing the film you know um and so
the initial idea was like i wonder if
there's any way to release the film on
kickstarter you know as something like
that but then you know as I started to
present that idea to care and she said
you know what I don't ously want to put
the film out there where we're gonna
have this goal and then if we don't
we're going to put in all this work in
all this energy if we don't meet the
goal then we're not gonna make any money
right though and so Carrie came at me
and wait what did you say care well I I
said you know I'd rather go with
something that if we don't make the gold
and we still can salvage some of the
money and the time that we put in so
yeah that being IndieGoGo um yeah so so
you know and as me and as we've looked
at it um you know in indy gogo seems to
be a very interesting platform for for
smaller like resource base films like
ours to go there as a way to use that
platform that you know it comes with a
lot of advantages and so we're going to
throw some of the stuff to you and at
this point this is where we kind of open
it up and we want you to sort of
question the whole the whole sort of
thing so so what we're going to do here
is we're going to use IndieGoGo in
collaboration with YouTube so we're
going to put the film on YouTube what
will have sort of a pinch video where we
tell our story whatever I need to go go
we'll have a goal and then and then in
the update section like once people
contribute
film then they'll be able to update
section the film will be readily
available and you just watch it
streaming right away you know that's
also a big part of it is we didn't want
there to be any friction we wanted you
know we want you know it's just like you
know that there's a quick sort of
payment process within you go go and
then it's like BAM then you're right
onto the film um there's no like there's
no like you have to download the movie
and wait a day or there's like there's
no delays right you get it you have
immediate access you can watch the film
and what I guess what we're both
fascinated and in terms of the whole
thing is we're really fascinated by
empowering the audience to get behind
something right away you know you know
we see that with crowdfunding efforts
where where the word starts to spread no
we've seen it often times with short
films you know where short films will
gain a lot more traction online than
they do going film festivals like you
know film festivals become very limited
they take their really just want its
drawn out yeah so do you have any early
thoughts that you know as we could take
this guy as I love the idea of using
IndieGoGo because you're making it you
know I mean that's why the studio to
spend the 30 or 40 million dollar
because you mentioned is that they're
trying to make it into an event it's not
just a movie that's available someplace
sometime like it's an event that you
want to go see the movie and so by doing
an IndieGoGo campaign you're making your
release and event you know I got an
online thing you don't have to spend 40
million dollars and that's a great idea
i love it and i think indiegogo is great
and yeah you certainly don't want to do
a distribution all or nothing and people
who were pledging money to watch the
movie and then them then don't get the
movie because you didn't make the goal
that would that would not make sense so
it certainly makes sense to do something
that's not all or nothing so yeah I
think it's a great idea and obviously
you have film courage the website to put
the widget on and blog about it to get
the word out and a presence on Twitter
and Facebook and all those things I
think the one thing that I would I would
wonder about would be because on YouTube
they only have the on
listed service right they only have like
it's still a link that anybody can just
type in and go to and I'm not a big
believer in prevention of piracy by you
know FBI warnings or by drm but for
people to know that it's on YouTube and
then to go in and pay money when they
just go over there and watch it anyway
it's not like they're going to be bad
people if they want to see the movie I
almost wonder if IndieGoGo in
conjunction with something that's a
little bit different might be an
alternate path and I know like for
example v HX it's one of these things
where that's actually what Aziz Ansari
used and they're great guys like then
people you can watch it streaming on any
of your devices but you can also then
download it and feel a sense of
ownership you know so that when you're
paying for something you then own it and
could watch it on any device whenever
and you know whether you had an internet
connection or not that kind of thing but
you know that's that's just you can work
that out however you want it you know i
think the indiegogo idea is great so I'm
excited about that well that was one of
our concerns you think I think you had
more faith that people would actually
want to pay for it whereas maybe I'm a
little more jaded where I thought well I
think people might if they can get away
with it then you know I mean we're all
guilty of it to some extent so we were
afraid of that of something in place
that some people just can't access it
for free and that's one dilemma that
we've come up against so um we need to
find a way probably to put a safety net
in place I don't know if there is one
yeah and you know this is all on this is
all new territory like we're all moving
west as it were so that there is no
right or wrong answer that we know of
necessarily you know like it's all going
to be experimentation between you guys
and me and the thousand other indie
filmmakers out there that are trying to
figure out a way to you know actually
get paid to do what we love and making
movies and all that so but yeah I think
it's a great idea from indy gogo and and
i'm sure and also i mean this this may
have been done
for it hasn't in the way that you guys
are doing it to my knowledge so that's
also just a great a great way of getting
headlines and getting coverage and
getting the word out like oh we're
actually distributing our movie using a
crowdfunding platform as opposed to just
doing a pre pre buying kind of period
and I'm sure that that will help with
you know IndieGoGo promoting you and
that kind of thing and you know sites
like no film school and filmmaker
magazine you know indiewire like people
covering distribution you become more of
a story by doing something innovative
that way too so that's great and
speaking of promotion that's one thing
that I really wanted to talk to you
about because you seem like you're
pretty sensitive to sort of the consumer
or the audience's needs likes and
dislikes and I'm curious how much
promotion is too much promotion because
we've all seen those campaigns where
it's just a little it just crosses the
line a little bit and then there's
summer there is no activity and it looks
like a beautiful project and nothing's
happening so what's to this yeah it's a
tough thing I definitely I have
definitely personally unfollowed people
on Twitter because you know they were
tweeting about their campaign every five
minutes for you know forty days or
actually have you guys thought about how
long you know IndieGoGo is not all or
nothing but they're still a limited
window have you thought about like I'm
not dodging the question but have you
thought about the time period of how
long you gonna do it yeah you know I'm
out I'm at a point where I you know I
believe 30 days no matter what the
campaign is no matter what the goal is
no matter what I think 30 days I think
the Internet I think word spreads really
quickly you know and I think I think I
think going beyond 30 days you're just
dragging it out yeah so essentially what
we're doing here is we're creating our
own 30 day window online where we're
giving people access all over the world
to tap in and see the film so you know
instead of like worrying about like the
studio window or the film festival
timeline or like or when is in itunes
going to release the film it's like no
no we can say okay this is
exactly when we want to do it we're
going to do it for 30 days and and you
know and get a sense of to get the
feedback and get a sense of how people
are responding to the film and then and
then we can clearly take it down off
online and now we can still do whatever
we know we can still explore those other
platforms right after that you know yeah
I think in terms of the like how much
motion is too much promotion thing it's
not necessarily the amount it's how
you're doing it and when people are just
repeating themselves over and over again
that's when you get annoyed with them
and you're like I don't want to see your
movie because you're annoying me
personally and you know but but I think
about the nice thing about doing a
limited 30-day campaign is that you have
a narrative to tell the story to tell
and just like with a movie if your
campaign has an arc people are going to
want to pay more attention to it than if
it doesn't and that's the nice thing
about when you have you have updates
trick oh you know we've reached this
milestone and this many people have seen
the movie and we're giving these great
quotes and reviews from people who've
watched it and all those kinds of things
make for you know interesting updates
for your followers as opposed to just
like watch our movie and then repeating
it over and over again and so I had a
rule when I was doing the manchild
campaign that I wouldn't talk about my
own thing twice in a row like if I was
on twitter i would like respond to
somebody or talk about somebody else's
campaign and talk about a movie or so
that every other thing at least wouldn't
be about me and you know it isn't that
sounds still pretty self-centered but at
least there was like a hard and fast
rule that I could like hold myself to
that I wasn't just constantly barraging
people me me me me me but yeah I think
you know a 30-day campaign at least you
have a story to tell and people are
going to want to pay attention to that
more than if you were just you know
barraging them endlessly you know I mean
let's open up you and further cool
because I know obviously yes the
unlisted thing on YouTube is sort of
this first wanny that people will get
access to film for free and obviously
that that's a major concern on our end
you know
that's what makes this whole thing that
much riskier and that was scarier but on
the other side indiegogo is not like
kickstarter in the sense that this is
where the double when he comes into play
where kickstarter you can send out
private updates to your backers okay
IndieGoGo updates are all public you
can't you can't do a private update on
IndieGoGo so okay initially when we were
thinking about this we were thinking
that IndieGoGo had the same capability
as kickstart right you know through our
experience with Kickstarter so it
becomes that much scarier the fact that
yes you know on one hand we're going to
be I'm going direct to the people give
them a chance to sort of follow the
scoreboard and hopefully become mostly
it involved whatever and pay but we're
not going to be able to stop nicely
though people that just wanted to see
the film hmm um so the updates can be
private but can you but you can message
your backers in on IndieGoGo like it
wouldn't have to be a public update you
could then send them here's the link to
them to the movie you bought right like
just via email or whatever the you know
messaging system is on IndieGoGo is that
I was gospel like I guess we do have to
clarify that in terms of the messaging
right you know because what's
interesting about this whole thing is we
own we have spoken Adam chap Nick who is
the CEO of this river read it and he's
also won one of like the chief people
and IndieGoGo as well he kind of heads
up the film Department on IndieGoGo and
no one has come to them and presented on
this idea so that that's what makes it
really scared it makes it scared us
because no one's like taking this path
yet and so yeah what we're essentially
going to attempt to hack this system you
know right you know you know like to
kind of to kind of modify it and use it
for our purposes in a way that that no
one else has done before so yeah that's
great thing I mean I like I said I think
that's what makes it
more of a story you know we all like you
know it's like what a studio goes out
there and does some alternate reality
game in the real world like to do
something new and innovative it's not
just because they think it's going to be
great for the participants but because
it generates headlines and because
people pay attention to that and want to
know how it works so you know that
should help you get additional attention
and you know that's a good thing I think
it'll be difficult but you know that's
what makes it worth doing so well in
terms of reaching out to whether the
indiewire or filmmaker magazine or the
LA Times what type of pitch letters work
for you I'm sure you're just all day
long you receive pitches and submissions
and press releases what works for you
what does um what's worked for me has
been telling a success story so it's not
you know it's like I think the great
thing about you guys is you have a
platform already so you can go out there
and film courage and do a big launch and
do one on social media and then when you
reach out to you know the amplifiers the
people we were talking about you can say
hey you know a X number of people have
purchased our movie in the first 24
hours and that's a story right there you
know like releasing a movie is not a
story because people release movies all
the time and they might cover you but if
you're also releasing a movie and you're
showing something new about distribution
and you've taken this innovative
approach that you are taking that's
something that becomes much easier for
people to write a story about and so you
know i think it's often about going to
that circle that you know is going to
watch your movie and getting them all on
board and then using that success story
to take it to the next level and that's
that's kind of what i tried to do with
the kickstarter campaign was you know
you go to new film school and say hey
you guys have been reading what i've
been writing for two years like I'm
trying to make a movie now can you help
me out and then when they thankfully did
then I was able to say okay well now we
have some credibility and some momentum
let's reach out to the basketball world
and so without that initial success I
don't think that would have worked and
so that's what i think is great about
you guys it's your position to have
you know people get on board the
campaign from the beginning and then
once you have a little you know once you
have some semblance of success and it
shows that it's working and that this is
a new thing that could work for other
people going forward then you have
theoretically the film film sites are
going to want to say hey this is
something we should cover you know so
don't put the cart before the horse kind
of because i know we differ on that i
know david always says wait till there's
some success in momentum for me I almost
love to hear someone's back story and
and that even if they haven't raised
like more than you know a hundred
dollars to me if there's a interesting
backstory I'm fascinated by it so I
think that's where we differ a little
bit but maybe just hold back a little
bit and wait till there's some steam
behind it well well that backstory is
not going to go away you know like when
you when people come to your campaign
has already been people watching it and
downloading it and reviewing it like you
know your back story is still the same
and everything but then it gives you as
somebody who's writing about content a
lot you're always thinking okay what's
the story here what's the headline you
know how and you want the person that's
pitching you to make it easy on you you
know if I have to go do some original
thought to figure out what I'm writing
about that's so much harder than if
someone just comes to me and says like
hey here's the story you know and it's
not that everyone's lazy but obviously
we're all really busy and we all get
tons of emails if someone comes to you
and it's a nicely packaged story then
it's going to be much easier for them to
cover it so I think you're right that
the back story is interesting and you
know all the crowdfunding campaigns that
do well for the most part it's not just
a matter of whether they have an
audience already but it's have they
presented themselves in a way that's you
know him pathetic and that you you
really want to help them but I don't
think there's things go away once a
project has momentum and starts getting
backers like you still have the
backstory and everything let me let me
let me cover some of the advantages of
indy gogo you know some things that just
to highlight some things here who that
you know that we find pretty interesting
here um you know obviously there's a
thing where you can sort of receive
payments worldwide so you know not
nothing you know not that we're going to
hit every single country but there's
just people in other english-speaking
countries that may take an interest in
the film and so so it does
sort of open it up where it's not so
geocentric to just one certain film
festival that's one thing that that's
enough to know they're sort of
detraction for me in terms of going
theatrical first or going to film
festivals first is because here you are
you're going to be / going to put all
this energy into like letting people
know about seeing your film but then at
the end of the day just only this small
group of people get to see it who
happens to be in that in that town or
city or whatever that theater you know
right and that's where we just wanted to
just open it up so that whoever wants to
see it don't have that opportunity right
off the bat you know and we can we have
this sort of 30-day window so you know
the fact that we can let IndieGoGo is
set up through paypal whatever and it's
sort of the worldwide thing and then
YouTube being able to be seen um oh you
know hopefully in all these places well
and you know so that's one thing another
thing is is if you look at the payment
system if you look at the Commission you
know if you start thinking of the
percentages that itunes is going to take
from you that that amazon is going to
take from you that dynamo is going to
take from you it now all of a sudden
look look at where any Go Go stands on
that if you reach your goal they're
gonna take four percent you know if you
don't reach their goal if you if you
don't reach the goal they're gonna take
nine percent nine percent is still a lot
lot better than then thirty percent from
itunes you know whatever the amazon you
know thing is and in dynamo thirty
percent or I think it's thirty percent I
I haven't even kept tracked track of all
brains I just know typically it's about
thirty percent for long the platforms um
you know then there's the transparency
the drain spare the transparency sort of
the scoreboard of like the goal you know
ideally that old kid continue to sort of
pull people back is like hey you know
and that's another scary thing we're
going when it's like and one thing is an
advantage but then it's also like if
we're for like five days in and we've
gotten a hundred people with to see the
film or pay to see it then then you know
then we're gonna have to live with that
as well so that that could be kind of
frightening well yeah I mean I think
everyone can talk about this place takes
thirty percent this takes this place
takes ten percent but
I mean all of us are just trying to get
to the point where those numbers
actually matter i mean you know like
thirty percent of like well they took
three dollars you know like it's not
it's not we're just trying to get to the
point where like enough people are
watching it that you're going to feel a
success regardless of whether it's
thirty percent of ten percent or you
know whatever it may be because compared
to the old days where some of them goes
and buys the DVD on the shelf at best
buy for twenty bucks and you the
filmmaker gets a dollar you know we're
doing much better than that in terms of
percentages now it's just a matter of
finding those people getting getting
enough an audience that and it you know
makes a difference but the nice thing
about IndieGoGo is you're creating
scarcity like you're creating this
limited thing and that's it makes it
more special as opposed to just okay my
movie is now on X service from here
until eternity go watch it whenever go
buy it whenever you know when you're not
lighting a fire under anyone to motivate
them say oh I'm gonna go watch that you
know so it's almost it's kind of like
theatrical in the sense that it's only
there for a limited time only you know
so that's great that's great right and
plus to the price point is it such a
change oh please well he has definite
ideas huh on the price point and my
Debra Lisbeth more but but please don't
know I do want to cover the price point
um you know what you said they're made
me think of pre-screen you know because
you don't appreciate first launch we
thought this is going to be interesting
because it's this online platform that
has scarcity and that has a window and
what we foresaw like when movie started
to come off the platform we figured
there was going to be a flurry of
activity because like okay you can no
longer see the film and and you know I
mean personally what I would I think
sort of you know I know I know um you
know what they wanted to do is they they
wanted it wasn't it was like kind of
like testing the audience and so what
necessarily i don't know i think the
price i still think I just don't agree
with the price point therefore
pre-screen I think they I think it was
like eighty dollars it was like I
started off as like four dollars the
first day and then like after that then
it was eight dollars and I think getting
people to spend eight dollars to rent a
movie
line right it's just too high you know
because otherwise I think we would have
saw we would have saw you know we would
have seen you know a florid activity in
those final day so yeah we certainly
hope that with this we hope that life as
he stay goes on you know sort of that
demand will hold because there's this
limited window to see the film mm-hmm
will you have yeah it's too it's too bad
about it's too bad about pre screens I
think you know they were getting your
legs under them and obviously it was a
it was a matter of experimentation and
they were getting you know their
facebook social proof things going all
this sort of stuff then obviously the
plug was pulled before we were really
able to see whether that model would
eventually work you know and that would
be something that would would seem to
make a lot of sense for film like yours
if if they had continued to grow and you
know so it's too bad at their that
they're not there anymore but I
definitely have thought a lot about
price points myself and the main time
that I think about it is when i turn on
my playstation which i use primarily as
a boot as a blu-ray player but if I go
into like a PlayStation Store and it's
like it's like twenty dollars to
download a digital file on my
playstation it's crazy like I'm not I
can't even get that off of my
playstation and put it on my iPad you
know I don't feel like I actually owned
this file but they want twenty dollars
for this you know this thing that I own
when so you know I you know the movie
industry is really following the music
industry in terms of its transition to
digital and the how much it's been
shaken up and I was in the music
industry when the music industry was
going down the tubes and the you know
prices of albums dropped a lot when
there was no longer a disk and shipping
and trucks and store shelves and all
those things that to take up part of the
percentages and it seems like a lot of
the studios who are you know selling
movies through PlayStation don't want
the price of their product to drop even
though there's no longer any physical
media or transportation costs so for us
as indie filmmakers if we're keeping
ninety percent and we're keeping seventy
percent
you know figuring out that price point
that gets people to buy it you know
you'll see that on amazon and itunes the
albums that are 7 99 or 899 tend to do
really well because people are thinking
about you know a lot of people are
saying well am I going to pirate this or
the album's only seven bucks and it's an
artist I support I'll go buy it you know
so so that's certainly I guess I talked
enough do you guys know what what a
price point you're you're going with
well here's what i want to do I mean I
you know you know certain Sears in the
other thing we don't we don't want to
just give them movie wait for free you
know because because we believe there is
value and truly distributing your work
you know and I think people i think
people will respect not just views but i
think i think people respect
transactions you know I just just just
part of what it is so you know and and
you know we can certainly benefit from
just a little bit of money that day
whatever a little bit that comes in will
take you know but so really what I want
to do is I want to just give the movie
away for a dollar that's kind of where I
stand and so what we're thinking about
doing here is we're thinking about
experimenting and so and I don't care
maybe wants a little bit high of a price
point for me I just want to just I want
to make it as frictionless as possible
but at the same time I don't want to
just give the movie way for free i want
i want people to pay i think that's a
really important part of the process so
i want to do it for a dollar and we're
going to make the experiment a little
bit is we'll have like an early bird
thing for like the first 100 people
where they pay a dollar and then we'll
have a price point of two dollars and so
that that's what I want to do and i
think karen is still wants to go a
little bit higher than that well you you
would want to do it where was the dollar
for the first thousand people and then
and I'm like hmm I think we should just
shrink it down just a little bit more so
I think we finally agreed on one hundred
as being like the early bird special for
me I'm thinking even 299 just you know
what dystrophy is what 399 something
like that so
something really I just think 2 99's
better but anyway I it's it's more it's
more your deal so I think that you
should have a say in that but so that's
what we're planning on doing just the
first 100 people one dollar and then
after that you know raise it a little
bit um and and for me I would actually
like to have it a longer campaign in 30
days I think have maybe 40 to 50 but I
know you're very you know your belief is
more is shorter and concentrated and I
see the pros to that so well but here's
the thing I mean here's the thing we can
you know we can always raise this we can
always do a second campaign you know I
mean but there's no there's no stopping
it from saying hey you know what the
first campaign is open it was so
successful whatever that hey let's just
do another one so we could we could let
you know theoretically go right into
another campaign if there's no stopping
us and doing there well well if anyone
goes and and you know pirates your movie
on YouTube when it's only a dollar they
should they should feel extra guilty but
I also you know the part of the thinking
of that also is that there's a
difference between streaming something
on the internet and you know downloading
it an HD and owning it or if you guys
had special features and
behind-the-scenes kind of things you
know so so even if you wanted the price
of entry to be low then maybe there's
the you might be able to have a higher
price point for you know download down
with behind the scenes that kind of
stuff in addition to the two like the
very low streaming price those are
things that I've been thinking about and
have no answers for but that's certainly
a low price and I'm very curious to see
how how it goes yeah yeah you know I
really I do want to just keep that
dollar point entry you know I you know
my whole thing is I want to try to
entice people as many people as possible
just to see the film you know and
obviously like I said we can't honestly
stop them from seeing it for free what
we want to have it so that you know
hopefully either the film itself or the
or just what we're doing you know all
the information that we're sharing this
this interview being one of the things
that we're sharing we're hoping that
we're giving people so much value that
you know and not to mention all the
value that we've provided the last few
years with what we've done with them
courage so we hope that like I guess
partly what we're hoping is we're hoping
that everything we've done is at least a
dollar putting the film itself it
doesn't necessarily inhibit people from
contributing more if they want to so if
they want if they wanted to say hey you
know what this isn't just for the film
we want to just we just want to give you
more money just for what you guys are
doing then it you know what we'll try to
present that as part of it but you know
but we we don't want to like you know
limited anyone that just says have a
dollar I want to give it up we wanted we
want to try to include everybody and
really what I want to do is have sort of
like as an experiment you know the first
100 people in early bird and then had
the two don't have it cost two dollars
just to kind of see like are people
giving a dollar are they or are they
giving two dollars or are they giving
more I'm courtesy like what that initial
hit will be and then part what I like to
do is I you know after the early bird
expires and it's rinse run out then I'd
like to just maybe do early birds too
and put it back at a dollar so I like to
just keep that price point depending
what we'll see how it goes but I would
like to keep that a secret so that
people don't know there's a second early
bird there was the wait for the flash
sale you know but yeah I think there's a
lot of interesting things going on in in
you know the online sales space whether
that be flash sales like Groupon which
we haven't really seen indie film them
do too much over you know
pay-what-you-want pricing like Radiohead
did that or you know Trent Reznor of
Nine Inch Nails did various tiers of
pricing for different you know packages
and the humble indie bundle the video
game online sale they're doing really
interesting things with charity
integrated and setting your own price
and I've been paying a lot attention to
what they're doing in terms of things
that I want to do eventually so you know
there is no set model but there's a lot
of interesting things going on and you
know also I think the thing that you're
being smart about is you know goodbye
promises I had a lot of improvident
right and you know you've been very
public about this is a
of low-budget film you know we didn't
have a whole lot of money and so the
hard thing for a lot of us to do is to
say hey I made a movie with no money now
pay us 20 bucks for it you know because
people know that like you didn't spend
any money and of course it's like it's a
little bit people you know your time is
the most valuable thing so much people
workin I'm really really hard like it's
not like it doesn't cost anything they
shouldn't be paid but it's also hard to
say it's like when a filmmaker has a
movie at a festival and they say well
we've been told not we've been
instructed not to talk about the budget
because you know your sort of cutting
back on value if you say we made this
for nothing so I think I think that's
what that's what you're doing that's
really smart is saying hey we made this
for nothing we're trying to get some
some money from it to support ourselves
as artists and we've set the price very
very low you know help us but but make
sure that you have an average for people
to pay more we want to pay you more you
know for as you mentioned everything
you've done up until now including film
courage and interviews and everything
that you've done because I think you
know people are going to want to do that
definitely come on more thought so um
you know and you know please any more
questions I actually one thing we
haven't covered yet is um you know and
please any more ideas or feedback or
anything please continue to fire away
but the overall goal we haven't talked
about if you were doing this what would
you set us the goal I have no idea well
I'll be nieto an independent film to get
your next project mate is reliant on
whether you paid your last investors
back right so making your money back
should certainly be a goal so you know
at the very least I would set it as what
you spent to make it so you know
obviously we all need to eat food and
support ourselves and all these kinds of
things but at the very minimum it should
be hey you know like we want to all the
money that we invested in this we want
to try and make that
back as a minimum goal so I you know it
depends on obviously on what the budget
level was but but that would be
certainly something that I would use as
a as a benchmark that's a good point
that's a good point yeah you know and I
guess you know where we're coming from
is when you said you want to make it
easy on the headlines as well you know
for people that may be be excited and
sort of the marketing component of it is
um you know and also you know part of
what we're coming from is you know let's
say we set a whatever a
two-thousand-dollar go a
five-thousand-dollar goal a
ten-thousand-dollar goal you know maybe
we recoup a lot of the money that we
that we then you know if some of our own
money that we put into the film it's
like that then we're giving ourselves
sort of this cap you know because you
know yes in extreme cases when when you
have like the bus monitor where you have
the small goal but it's such as such a
compelling story that just strikes a
nerve then you'll see something to shoot
through the roof but in most cases
whatever the goal is it's like you know
that the money that come in come comes
in tends to hover around that so so with
all that my week that's that's I was
going to say that's the case a lot more
on Kickstarter where it's all or nothing
because people tend to make that push to
make their goal at the end I think on
IndieGoGo I've seen a lot of projects
they tend to vary a lot more because
it's not you know it's not all or
nothing but I think it's also helpful to
think about it in terms of what you
think your audience sizes and how many
people going to watch the movie because
if people are just paying a dollar for
your movie that's a lot of people that
are going to see it if you make it to
five or ten thousand dollars you know
like it so that and now is actually one
of the reasons why I had on my man child
campaign i made the minimum backing
level five dollars is not that i was
like i don't want your dollar but
because the goal was so high I was like
you know half people on earth could back
his campaign I feel like I wouldn't make
my goal because that one dollar like it
wouldn't you know that's not
statistically significant in terms of
how many people you think can help you
all along the way so
you know your goal is definitely
dependent on how many people not
necessarily how much money you think are
going to see it and are going to want to
see it yeah that's a great point ya know
we you know what we're looking to do is
we're gonna set a very high goal you
know and we realize that we're not going
to hit the goal but but we we feel that
you know the whole marketing angle and
just putting it out there it gives us a
reason to wake up every day and work
hard you know absolutely toward the
impossible goal so we're gonna we're
going to set the goal at at a million
dollars and we're going to make it we're
going to try think we're going to try to
get there one by one so you know cuz
really what we're fascinated by I get
we're fascinated by by empowering the
audience you know we're we offer me I'm
really fascinated you know because when
I come back when I want to think of like
Ed Burns and Morgan Spurlock and amanda
palmer and louis ck you know and yes
they're established names but sometimes
you know especially not with social
media and networks and and and and just
the power of the internet i believe that
yes you know maybe we're not ed burns
but but if you get a small group of
people together and if you pull that
energy together you might not be that
far off that burns you know you might be
closer than you think it is what i
believe i believe if you can get a small
group of passionate people to just
constantly just share and spread the
idea because when when you look at the
amount of work that went into ed burns
promoting nice guy johnny he was really
sort of a one-man army I didn't really
see a lot of press coming from a lot of
the past involved in a film like Ed
Burns was doing all the interviews he
was the one that was talking up the film
and he kind of you know he put a lot of
that on his back and I'm just really
care to see if we get some folks from
our team to put some energy behind
something and then if some of sort of
like the super fans um start getting
excited getting involved i'm curious to
kind of see what happens if we can cry
you know create a small little snowball
and just keep pushing it forward see
what happens so oh wait I think I think
something that can also help is that if
you give you said like am I
stone or something then people feel
invested in your success like if this
campaign reaches five thousand dollars
then everybody who backed gets this
other thing also like there are bonuses
for people you to be invested in your
success and to promote it and to see
other people you know the more people
that watch your movie the better the
product actually gets I think there's a
lot of power and those things in terms
of you know like bundles they'll often
say like well if we reach this cold then
it also includes this other thing and
with a single movie that can be hard but
you know there's lots of
behind-the-scenes stuff and you know you
can even if you hadn't recorded a
director's commentary you can say hey if
we reach five thousand dollars then I'll
go recorded directors commentary and
that'll be free for everybody who's back
and then people will want to be pushing
you towards that goal so to give people
an investment in your success and for
them to want to see you succeed then for
the product that they've already back to
get better because of it I think it'd
also be a powerful thing yeah yeah
that's all that's all part of the plan
because that the challenge is is we just
we just have this movie you know and we
want to keep the price point low and so
and when I say like I want things to be
frictionless like I want I want it to be
easy on our end as well as the audience
and you know and obviously you know I'm
sorry but I'm sure for you as without me
for you you have many more backers get
behind manchild than we did for triple I
promise but but there's the fulfilling
of all the rewards you know and we
didn't want to get caught on this
distribution side of things where we
have to fulfill all these rewards but I
want it to be seamless on our end and so
so that's why we just want to keep it
really simple like you know it's like
it's like you there's only like the one
dollar option the two-dollar option and
then there's nothing else but then but
then you know we do want us you know so
we can't we can't reward individual
backers but like as you're saying what
we can try to do is we can't try to
reward the group you know we can try to
yeah absolutely
as we hit the milestone so that that's
what we've been thinking about is is is
um you know for like the first 228
backers we're going to offer up a
promotional tweet well you know you know
you know our film Kurds has a little bit
of reach so anyone that's in one of
those those early people will send out a
promotional tweet on that that's one
thing that we're willing to do to kind
of help hopefully build a little
momentum and then we'll set you know
group reward at like five hundred at a
thousand and we have it going all the
way up you know if we get to an
ambitious level I know there's there's
um there's some what they call the
imprint Improv Everywhere skin you know
Karen Karen ohm is may be willing to an
improv everywhere skit then you know
that this is sort of like a funny thing
that will do over your free reads like a
higher level so yeah we definitely want
to incorporate that and get people sort
of incentive to sort of follow the story
along with the movie and then the
campaign sounds good I look forward to
it and you know would definitely of
course covered it on no film school it's
the yeah it's the one outlet I control
so we'll definitely definitely covering
it all right well you know that that's
good because that would be a good kick
in the butt for me too hopefully you two
maybe write something if you're up for
you know maybe not just one more of
these thoughts but you know but if
there's any coverage you guys can do one
you're in um you know we certainly would
be meet you you know the reach that yuki
that you've prayed it over there is it's
really something special you know thank
you it really is so um you know we find
ourselves every day trying to be more
like cool yeah yeah What Would kudu
basically well you know we'll see uh
hopefully hopefully all you know I'll be
in the same boat as you guys in a year
and I'll be to try and figure out my own
distribution quandary but um you know
people like you coming up with
innovative ways of distributing a movie
digitally online it's been the thing
that I've been interested in for the
last five years you know since since the
first time you watch a movie on your
computer instead of a DVD player you
know so i look forward to following how
this goes and doing whatever small
I can't promote it and yeah just uh you
know break a leg oh thank you yeah and I
guess just lastly cool if you don't let
you know just your overall thoughts you
know now that you're taking a step back
and you've heard more of the idea you
know you know risk versus reward I mean
would you say yes you know you guys need
to go ahead and do this or we or would
you say you know what it's not quite the
time to go ahead and do something like
this oh absolutely do it I think you
know obviously you put a lot of great
thought into doing something that's new
and it's different and not not just for
the sake of being different but because
you've taken a look at the landscape for
what it is and tried to figure out you
know how to insert yourself in a way
that can potentially make a splash and I
think with a one dollar price point the
advantage that you get is that you know
your indie in the sense that you're
accessible and you're not you're doing
the opposite of what a lot of studios
are doing and that's great the challenge
is going to be because it's a
crowdfunding campaign there's a goal but
it's not all or nothing and so I'm used
to all or nothing world where those
things are much more carefully
calculated you know like you know you go
get the headline with the million-dollar
the million-dollar goal but but i would
definitely think about you know i don't
know how indiegogo works for there's
like there's milestones i was talking
about you know just hitting hitting
something along the way i think can be a
powerful thing but yeah i love the idea
of just distributing three indiegogo you
know that's a great it's a great idea
and i look forward to it and just to
play the devil's advocate for a second
even if it's not a big splash i mean the
chances of us making a million dollars
are very slim we know that but what are
the positives of kind of like you know
go big or go home kind of a thing like
what right even if we fall flat on our
face which you could definitely happen
what's the benefit of that because i'm
sure there is something that there's
we gain from that well I think we all
want you know we're all watching the
olympics now you want to see somebody
who's just been going for for the last I
mean this is your Olympics you know
you've been working on this you've been
training for this for 44 years now and
we don't as filmmakers we only make a
movie once every four years maybe you
know so I had written something on no
film school about it that small goals
tend to fall through because you just
say oh well that didn't happen you know
so what we're has really large goals
that you set or what motivate you to
push yourself and give it your all and I
think in that case when you've given it
your all if you don't make a goal your
fun with it because you you know if you
just worked all day you didn't sleep and
you did that the entire time you know
you say hey I did my best and I learned
something from it and my next movie you
know now I'll know the things I'm new on
this one and that's what we all do like
not all of us are going to make great
movies every time you know we're all
going to have failures no matter how
talented we are you know there are a
million things we can't control but if
we give it our all and we work as hard
as we can we learn something you know I
think that makes us much better prepare
for the next thing and so I like the
ambition and the fact you're going
forward and you know you're going to
work your ass off for it and whatever
happens you know you can be proud of
that it's great i got the right answer
that's a great way to cap it all off coo
once again we just feel so grateful to
you you know we continue to be inspired
by owned by no film school we're
probably we're proud supporters and
manchild that someone email us three
days ago just love the episode with coos
oh yeah that's true okay well hopefully
this will be interesting for someone to
watch somewhere we're seven you know if
you're watching this go by their movie
for ten dollars don't listen to any
don't don't pay a dollar given ten I
deserve it thank you we appreciate the
time thank you thank you thank you good